here I was in lower Manhattan and I
heard the heard the sound of the first
plane hitting the tower and it was a
very strange metallic gear sound and
then about ten minutes later I was told
that a plane had hit we were told it was
a small plane the first news was that it
was a small plane and strange but you
know we went on getting ready for the
day and then when the second plane hit
everybody knew it was not a nice I
wasn't my way back from work when I had
it on the news just the first plane
hitting and I was a bit worried already
then cause it sounded very strange and
when I got home I was just switched on
the television when the second plane hit
and I sat on my bed with my kids and I
felt like well this is gonna change
everything everybody I worked because
everyone was numbed we went to again all
the everyone start working everybody was
watching it on their computers at lunch
when we'd go to the gym we just stood
there and watched on TV just nobody
could work that day we just wanted to
almost go home obviously a devastating
day I'll never forget that